hello everyone welcome to the langfocus
channel and my name is
paul today we're going to talk about one
of the most linguistically diverse
countries in the world
that country is india the exact number
of languages spoken among
india's 1.3 billion people is hard to
pinpoint exactly
different sources give different numbers
and that's partly because they have
different ideas about what can be
classified as a separate language
as opposed to a dialect according to
ethnologue there are 448 languages
according to the people's linguistic
survey of india there are 780 languages
and then there's the indian census data
on the indian census
people can call their mother tongue
whatever they want and there was a total
of 19
569 different language names among the
responses
of course that's way too high there
aren't even that many languages in the
whole world
some people probably just call the same
language by different names depending on
their
locality or ethnicity those 19569 names
were grouped into 1
369 mother tongues and each of those
mother tongues are further grouped under
one of 121
languages but that only includes
languages with 10 000 or more speakers
so there must be more india has two
official languages
at the national level hindi and english
there are also
22 scheduled languages each state or
union territory of india is free to
choose its own official language or
languages
and these are recognized and encouraged
by the national government
most of the languages of india fall into
either of two families
the indo-aryan family a branch of the
indo-european language family which is
predominant in northern india
and the dravidian language family which
is predominant in southern india
the remainder mostly belonged to the
austro-asiatic sino-tibetan and thai
kadai language families
these are the top 10 most spoken
languages in india according to the
census
for each language the numbers include
all of the mother tongues associated
with that language
if we define the language more narrowly
then the numbers might be lower for each
language
for example the total for hindi includes
the languages of the hindi belt the area
where hindi proper
forms a dialect continuum with related
languages like the rajasthani languages
and most of the bihari languages and the
pahadi languages
these languages are linguistically
distinct from hindi but are closely
related to it
and since hindi is the main official
language in the states of the hindi belt
people often think of their languages as
local varieties of hindi
it does not however include urdu even
though urdu
and hindi are essentially the same
language with different standard forms
for more information about the
relationship between hindi and urdu
check out my video on that subject from
a couple of years ago
the dravidian languages the origin of
the dravidian languages is not known and
they share no clear links with any other
language family
however there are theories that the
dravidian languages could be linked with
the uralic language family including
hungarian and finnish or the disputed
altaic language family which includes
turkish mongolian korean and japanese
it's generally thought that dravidian
was present in india before the arrival
of the indo-european language
more than 3500 years ago the oldest
existing
dravidian writings are the tamil brahmi
inscriptions some of which date back to
the 3rd or 4th century bce
and some more recently discovered
inscriptions may be even older
and the extensive tamil literary
tradition goes back
earlier than 300 bce though we don't
have original inscriptions of those
there are also inscriptions with some
telugu words that date from sometime
between
400 bce and 100 bce there are also
fragments of the kannada language dating
back to the 3rd century bce
keep in mind that these are just the
oldest inscriptions and literature that
we know about
the languages are certainly older than
that but of course they've all developed
a lot since those early days
a few features of dravidian languages in
terms of grammar
dravidian languages are agglutinative
the root word comes first
and suffixes are attached to add meaning
this sentence means i
eat mango non mambaram sapidurain
this is the root verb meaning eat this
suffix shows the present tense
and this suffix shows the first person
singular now in the future tense
i will eat mango non mambaram
here's the verb root this suffix
indicates future tense
and again this is first person singular
the most common word order is
sov as we just saw in those sentences
above but the word order is flexible
the major dravidian languages have all
been significantly influenced by
sanskrit
the ancient indo-aryan language in which
the hindu scriptures and classical epics
like the ramayana and mahabharata were
written
for kannada telugu and malayalam i've
seen claims that sanskrit words account
for 65 to 80
of the vocabulary but i'm not sure
there's a way to calculate that
with precision it's true that in writing
and an educated speech a lot of sanskrit
words are used
but much less so in the rural areas and
among less literate people
tamil is the most conservative of the
major dravidian languages
and has been influenced by sanskrit the
least this has contributed to the myth
that tamil is the mother of all the
dravidian languages but that's not the
case
all dravidian languages including tamil
trace back to a proto-dravidian language
though malayalam developed from a
dialect of tamil or a language
very closely related to tamil and then
became sanskritized
the indo-aryan languages while the
dravidian languages have been influenced
by sanskrit the indo-aryan languages are
directly descended from sanskrit
sanskrit one of the oldest indo-european
languages goes back at least 3500 years
it continues on in its classical form as
a liturgical and literary language to
this day
but sanskrit and its associated dialects
developed over time into procrits
middle indo-aryan languages that were
divergent from sanskrit
these procreate languages then developed
into the indo-aryan languages of
northern india
much in the same way that latin
developed into vulgar latin
and then into the romance languages
while much literature was written in the
various procreates of each region
classical sanskrit remained the language
of high culture throughout the indian
subcontinent
the name prakrit comes from the sanskrit
word prakrita
meaning unrefined or natural because
they were naturally arising vernacular
forms of language
the name sanskrit comes from the
sanskrit word samskrita
meaning perfected or refined because
sanskrit was an ideal or standardized
literary language most indians will tell
you that sanskrit maintained this status
because it enables us to communicate
with precision
one well-known procreate is pauli which
is widely studied because it's the
language of the teravada buddhist
scriptures
in the language of buddha himself was
likely either pali or the closely
related maghadi prakrit
magadhi prakrit is one of the three
major prakrits from which the modern
indo-aryan languages are thought to
descend
magadhi is the ancestor of the eastern
indo-aryan languages
including bengali and others sharasini
prakrit is the ancestor of the central
indo-aryan languages
which include the hindi languages
maharashtri prakrit
is the ancestor of the southern
indo-aryan languages including konkani
marathi as well as sinhala of sri lanka
and dhihavi of the maldives
just as the dravidian languages have
been influenced by sanskrit
the indo-european languages have also
been influenced by dravidian languages
due to contact over the millennia
even sanskrit contains some dravidian
vocabulary phonetic influence and
grammatical influence
but influence has also taken place over
time since then due to continuous
contact especially in languages
bordering the dravidian areas
like marathi and odia marathi for
example contains a significant amount of
agglutination
which is a dravidian feature we saw
earlier and it contains a lot of
dravidian vocabulary
but some degree of this kind of
influence extends throughout northern
india
there has indeed been a large south
asian sprachbund
an area in which various languages
influence each other
as part of the indo-european language
family the indo-aryan languages are not
agglutinative like the dravidian
languages but rather fusional with some
being more analytic than others
in other words having fewer inflections
interestingly the indo-aryan family
contains only one tonal language
punjabi one of the few tonal
indo-european languages
one important feature of the indo-aryan
languages is that they were all
significantly influenced by persian
and to a lesser extent turkic and arabic
because of centuries of largely turkic
muslim rule
the delhi sultanate first introduced the
persian language and its literary
tradition
in the 13th century and this continued
with the mughal empire from the 16th
century
up until the beginning of british rule
persian was the official language of the
empire the lingua franca of the elite
and a prestigious literary language here
are a few simple examples of everyday
words in hindi that came from persian
the word for vegetable sabzi comes from
persian
sabzi the word for book ketab
comes from persian and ultimately came
from the arabic word
kitab the word for fresh or new
comes from persian the word for warm
garam comes from persian
those are just a few examples of the
many words that are used
it's interesting to note that in urdu
these words are the same but look
exactly like the persian words
because urdu is written in the perso
arabic script urdu is the indian
language that is most heavily influenced
by persian
standard hindi and urdu both developed
from the same kadibuli dialect of delhi
but while standard hindi is more
sanskritized urdu is more persianized
and arabized
there was much less persian influence on
the dravidian languages
that's probably because northern india
was more consistently under muslim
control than the south
it's also probably because the
indo-aryan languages are closer to
persian to begin with
sino-tibetan two of the 22 scheduled
languages are sino-tibetan languages
boro and mete also known as manipuri
boro is co-official in the himalayan
state of assam
and official in its borderland
autonomous region which borders bhutan
mete is the official language of the
state of manipur which borders myanmar
the many sino-tibetan languages in
northeastern india belong to the
tibeto-burman sub-family
and are grouped geographically into a
branch of tibeto-burman
but the exact relationship between many
of these languages is unclear
northeastern india is the most
linguistically diverse
area of the country with around 75
percent of the country's languages
despite its relatively small area and
population
many of the languages also feature great
dialectal variation with sometimes low
mutual intelligibility
making it necessary to use a separate
lingua franca for communication
boro and mete function as lingua francas
between the various linguistic
communities in their respective areas
but a more widely used lingua franca is
assamese the eastern most
indo-european language and the other
official language of assam
there are also assam-based pidgin and
creole languages
notably nagamese in the state of
nagaland
while its vocabulary is based on
assamese its grammar is rooted in
tibeto-burman languages
in arunachal pradesh where as many as 50
tibeto-burman languages are spoken
english is the only official language
while hindi is the main lingua franca
tibeto-burman languages are also spoken
in makaleya
but the official language of the state
is english and the most widely spoken
native language is kasi
an austroasiatic language one of the 22
scheduled languages
santali is also an austroasiatic
language
it's a recognized regional language
spoken in a number of states in eastern
and northeastern india
there are numerous other languages in
india belonging to the same munda
branch of austroasiatic austroasiatic
doesn't sound indigenous to india does
it
the austroasiatic language family is the
family that includes vietnamese and the
khmer language of cambodia
it's thought that speakers of languages
arrived in india more than 3500 years
ago
santali had no written language until
the 19th century
a special script called old chiki was
created specifically for the suntali
language
scripts are one of the most intriguing
aspects of india's linguistic diversity
according to the people's linguistic
survey of india 66 different scripts are
used
most of the languages use scripts
derived from the ancient brahmi script
the oldest readable script of the
subcontinent the only one older than the
brahmi script is the indus script
symbols appearing in inscriptions that
date back as far as 5500 years ago
but it's not known whether this is an
actual script or just a set of pictorial
symbols
devanagari this is the most widely used
script in india
it's used for hindi and a number of
other modern languages
and is also widely used for sanskrit the
gujarati script
was developed from deva nagari and is
used for writing gujarati the bengali
script derived from deva nagari and is
used for writing bengali and sometimes
meite
the assamese script is nearly identical
to the bengali script
and is used to write the assamese
language the gurmukhi script is used to
write punjabi
then there are dravidian scripts which
also derive from the brahmi script the
tamil script is used to write tamil
telugu also has its own script and the
kannada language has a script that's
very similar
malayalam also has its own script all of
these dravidian scripts are also used to
write a number of minority languages and
sanskrit in their respective regions
all of these brahmi-derived scripts are
abugida scripts
scripts in which vowels are connected to
a base consonant and the two can't be
separated
even though these scripts all derived
from the same source being able to read
one
doesn't mean you can read the others
without first learning them
and that brings me to an important
question with all of this linguistic
diversity
how do indians communicate with people
who speak different native languages
well my understanding is that in
northern india because the indo-aryan
languages are closely related they can
become mutually intelligible through
exposure
but without exposure their speakers can
probably just pick out certain words in
the other language
many non-hindi speakers can understand
hindi through exposure even though they
may not be able to speak it very well
so if they talk to a hindi speaker then
there may be one-way intelligibility or
asymmetric
intelligibility but if the hindi speaker
learns to understand their language
through exposure then they may speak to
each other in their own languages and
understand each other
but many indians are multilingual so
they might fully communicate in hindi or
in the other language
or they might communicate in english
english becomes even more important when
indo-aryan speakers communicate with
dravidian speakers since their native
languages are very different
and there may be some pride that
prevents them from speaking the other
language
of course this is also true for the
other languages belonging to the
sino-tibetan and austroasiatic families
among others
and it's worth emphasizing that every
state or area has many languages spoken
but one particular language might
dominate and be used as a lingua franca
and it may not be hindi or english it
might be the official language of that
state or
it might be the most predominant
language in that area but many indians
have told me that in general they just
tend to spend more time with people who
speak the same language as them
the question of the day for people from
india what's your native language
and what other languages do you know in
what situations do you use them
and to people who have visited india
assuming you tried to speak english
there
how well were you able to communicate
with people in english leave your
answers in the comments below this video
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
check out the various langfocus
social media accounts and once again
thank you to all of my wonderful patreon
supporters especially these people right
here on the screen they are my top tier
patreon supporters
so many special thanks to them and to
everyone thank you for watching and have
a nice day
[Music]
you